the biggest challenge in Afghanistan is
putting the people first putting the
people's security first putting their
economic development first putting their
education and healthcare first when we
first went in and we toppled the Taliban
we were we genuinely were greeted as
liberators as a forces that would give
ordinary Afghans a better life and we
had a lot of support from ordinary
people and that support is essential to
defeating al Qaeda and other terrorist
groups because you have to have the
cooperation of the population or put
another way the population can't be
continually terrorized by visitors in
the night if they're working with you
and people come in the night and
threaten them or kill members of their
family and you can't stop that you'll
stop getting that cooperation very
quickly and that's exactly how the
Taliban operates and how al Qaeda
operates we've been focused on the
central government on Kabul on getting a
democracy but that central government is
incredibly weak and in many ways very
corrupt and what's happening in the
different provinces is the people
themselves are less and less secure and
they're starting to play a double game
you know if he'll talk to us but they'll
talk to them the Afghans have had to do
that for centuries and in the end like
all people they're going to put their
own family their own clan their own
tribe first so what we have to do is
first of all change our military
strategy where instead of being on bases
our troops have to get out into the
villages which is no easy feat in a
country as mountainous as Afghanistan
effectively you're talking about a
series of narrow valleys that are cut
off from the next Valley but our
strategy has to be to be in with the
people so when they're attacked we're
attacked and we defend and that they
understand we're not just sitting on our
bases coming out and showing the flag
we're actually there for them and that
we will
be there for them until we push back the
people who are menacing them as much as
anything else that's a big shit change
in strategy that's going to require our
commitment over years and the commitment
of other forces NATO forces and indeed
as stronger ultimately a stronger Afghan
government but we're going to have to
put more in before we can start pulling
out in that country but it's essential
because those the forces they're
fighting really are the forces who are
who gained strength by attacking the
west